happy Monday reject nation good to see
you today so I just discovered that the
Luke Cage season 2 trailer has dropped
Luke Cage I really did love the first
season a hell of a lot I even like the
last few episodes you know the part
where you if you gotta want to ruin this
show there's a very obvious part where a
lot of fans were split on how they felt
about certain character name Diamondback
I like binge watch at that one time
currently on Jessica Jones Season 2
we're actually doing full-length TV show
reaction watch alongs on our patreon
John and I check out our patreon if you
want to watch it along with us we're
halfway through the show right now on
the Luke 8 season two finally got an
official trailer I hope daredevil season
3 is next so wanted to give a patient
the day shout out to Adelia chamberlain
because i remember a few weeks ago
actually you know she's someone who
binge the entire MCU movies she was also
telling me how she was binging all the
Marvel Netflix shows as well she's
someone who really is a hardcore Marvel
fanatic if Luke Cage is Power Man you
were power one man I'll tell you that
much Adelia you're someone who's had to
deal with a lot of obstacles along the
way we talked plenty of times you're
someone who is constantly having to
overcome obstacles so while you may not
be a superhero in the physical strength
you are a powerful woman for always
moving forward that no matter what hell
you're going through you keep going and
you keep coming out on the other side so
I'm proud of you my dear anyway let's
watch Luke Cage season 2 trailer
yo whoa I'm Luke Cage hate to see such a
positive brother like Luke Cage go down
like that
anyone who can take you on bed and it
can't be good for
he's like kind of traumatized a fine
[Music]
Bushmaster Umberto Campbell have to find
out
Bushmaster nice singing raw didn't have
a brutal sometimes portunity get [ __ ]
done
Esmeralda's meet a human it be a queen
the darkness that you deal with every
day
we can't conceive a whole
[Music]
[Music]
Wow what a meadow way to end that that's
really ice there's just some quick
thoughts right when the trailer started
one of the things I was immediately
reminded of was how amazing the
soundtrack was in the first season the
entire time the trailer was going I was
just feeling all of that there's some
interesting meta things that are sort of
happening you not meta has a metahuman
but that is happening you know like that
last line it's my show even at the
beginning when it looked like he was
talking directly to the camera what she
was as I don't know his Luke Cage
starting a YouTube channel or something
or is he doing one of those things where
I'm gonna put up a video cuz I'm gonna
send a message that I'm haarlem's hero
which is always a cool thing to do maybe
one day I'll do that for this channel
I'm gonna protect the streets of North
Hollywood with the reactions in the
first season he's being introduced and
Harlem is getting to know who luke
cage's the cops are getting to know who
luke cage's it seems like at the
beginning of this season he's obviously
will have an established reputation I
love that moment with the gangsters they
have their assault rifles and you're
like we just got a show that we tried
and then for his reputation to be taken
down by Bushmaster I'm not gonna act
like I know everything about someone
like Bushmaster yeah some Phil Nolan I'm
the master of the book not really living
superhero context when viral videos just
changed the reputation of a superhero
but Bushmaster if I recall correctly
just minor information cuz I heard some
speculation a while ago that Bushmaster
would be in this show so looking him up
he has a criminal organization which it
seems to be here he does go through the
same experiments that Luke Cage went
through and he ends up being even more
powerful and he actually dawns is pretty
cool outfit that has like a tail on it
and I think for a season to mash up for
him to go up against someone who has the
similar type of power but is more on the
evil side I think works you know you had
two villains in season one and I'm one
of them had superpower yeah one of them
had an ability that allowed a certain
type of super strength but not just as a
human was he
super-powerful some people get tired of
that and like the Marvel formula in the
movies we're just this hero's going up
against someone with the same exact
power but I think for a season two
that's a little bit more appropriate
because we're very well established Luke
agencies in one misty night with the
bionic arm I think in the comics misty
Knight gets that from Stark Industries
but based off what happens in the
defenders I'm assuming that is made from
Danny ran his company and that looks
really cool to have them working
together in the fact that she's going
out in the streets and kicking ass as a
vigilante more than just the cop the
first announcement I heard about this
show was that iron fist and Colleen wing
we're supposed to be in here and I'm
kind of surprised and show them in the
trailer however I'm pretty relieved they
didn't show them in the trailer because
it keeps it focused solely on luke
cage's journey and maybe in a later show
the show door or maybe they'll be cool
about it and just let it happen in the
show because I would like to see the
Heroes for Hire element thrown in here
with Power Man and Iron Fist and I'd
like to see the daughters of the Dragon
element thrown in here with Colleen wing
and misty Knight that's something I'm
even looking more forward to and I'm
like Jessica Jones season two the fact
that she has the bionic arm misty Knight
I feel like they'll have to really
acknowledge certain events that happened
in the defenders and especially if iron
fists will be coming into the show
because Jessica Jones season two doesn't
seem to acknowledge any of that but I
feel like with Luke Cage you'll have to
link it up in a tighter way than how
Jessica Jones is not acknowledging it at
all it's cool and Mariah shades are back
we all know they're coming back that's
there's a big cliffhanger season 1 so
all the focus seems to be going on this
bushmaster character going up against
Luke Cage there has to be some super
strong tie-in maybe Mariah and shades
are the ones who are able to cut a deal
with Bushmaster and bring him in to
Harlem to take on Luke Cage maybe
they'll rework some of the elements of
the comic book to help him get the
powers or something like that or maybe
he's just another new gangster who
wishes to take over Harlem territory and
Mariah and shades are going up against
him as well I think the last thing I
want to mention is you know I don't want
to spoil anything about infinity war
these shows will always refer to the
Battle of New York as the incident
there's a whole new incident that took
place and I kind of feel like this show
has to acknowledge it or maybe even
daredevil season 3 has doing
these shows are connected to the MCU
even though the movies don't seem to
really care about them this show is
greatly acknowledge that they are
connected to the MCU films and after the
events of infinity war I feel like there
has to be some type of acknowledgment
guys I'm excited for this show and I
really can't wait for is the daredevil
season 3 trailer but I'm excited for
this show thanks for watching you guys
can subscribe and become part of the
reject nation click that notification
Belko subscribe buttons don't really
work and check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
s would love to have you become a
patronage act today